so I mean obviously this is why I spend
my whole career working on this is that
if I think if we do this right it's
going to be the greatest thing ever
happened humanity and in some ways I
think unlock our full potential
I mean I've talked a lot about in all my
talks about using it as a tool to help
us make science and medical
breakthroughs faster that's something
that's an obvious one but sort of taking
that longer term one reason I got so
into a AI is that like probably many of
you in this room you know I'm
interesting the biggest questions of why
we're here understanding our minds what
is consciousness what's the nature of
the universe what's our purpose and if
we're going to try and really grapple
any of those questions I think we're
going to need something like AI perhaps
without salt enhanced as well too and I
think you know in that future world will
have a chance to actually find out about
some of these really deep questions you
know in the same way we're finding out
without forego just about go but what if
we could do that with all of science and
physics and and and you know the biggest
questions in the universe and I think
you know that's going to be the most
exhilarating journey of all to find that
out you know to kiss carry that on a few
other things that people commented on is
you know in terms of like you know us as
the most intelligent beings on the
planet right now and treating animals
badly and these sort of things I think
if you think about it though you know
let's take you know I don't know Tigers
or something in India they have huge
Rangers and those people very poor and
they they they're a resource poor but if
they had abundant resources I don't
think they're intentionally trying to
kill off these Tigers well I mean some
in some cases they are but often it's
just because they need the land for
their cattle and that's this the tiger
needs you know whatever a number of
kilometers where kilometers to live one
tiger and it's just difficult with a
number of people that are there so I
think if we solve the kind of abundance
and scarcity problem then I think that
opens up you know I think a lot of
conflicts both you know between humans
as well as to do with reason or scarcity
at but at the heart of it so I see a you
know if we can solve a lot of these
problems I can see a much better huge